you stay stuck in the way that that
you've been moving you're gonna keep
getting what you've been getting out of
life and that's not the way life is
meant to be Liz it's so many things that
you go through in this game and so many
evidence lo so many ups and downs people
that truly keep going that make it you
know you got to create the kind of
energy that you want in your life if you
constantly keep creating positive energy
around you the more positive things will
come so he's an American radio presenter
and TV personality he's a co-host of a
nationally syndicated radio show The
Breakfast Club he currently stars in and
hosts MTV to show uncommon sense with
Charlamagne tha God Charlamagne tha God
and here's my take on his top 10 rules
for success also guys as you're watching
if you hear something that really
resonates with you please leave it down
the comments below and put quotes around
it so other people can be inspired also
when you write it down it's much more
likely to lock in for yourself as well
enjoy
so after you've entered a good the bad
the ugly what do you know for sure about
life that it moves on between the center
it's the truth that it moves on and
keeps going and guess what it's going to
move on and keep going with or without
you so you know you better adjust to the
changes because if you don't adjust to
the changes ran and you say you stay
stuck and the way that that you've been
moving you're gonna keep getting what
you've been getting out of life and
that's not the way life is meant to be
less life life is meant to be lived
you got to constantly evolve you know
changes the phases of growth and growth
is the basics or legs if you're not
constantly changing and I grow on if
you're not growing then what are you
doing and you're dying you're not doing
nothing
so that's why when you look at certain
people man you see them in their
40-something years old if they washed up
but they still trying to live the way
they were when they were in their 20s
and 30s nothing about them as grown
nothing about them is evolved their
mindset has grown their mindset hasn't
evolved they're still hanging around the
same people they was hanging around when
they were in their 20s doing nothing so
guess what if you're hanging around the
same people that you were hanging around
in your 20s doing nothing guess you're
gonna be doing your 30s nothing suggests
you were doing your forties nothing so
you got understand life moves on by the
time don't wait for nobody man and when
it's over it's over when you're 47 years
old and you look back and you like
saying I wasted all that time doing
nothing
you know life moved on and I didn't move
with it
now you're just a washed individual
y'all got nobody to blame for that with
yourself be yourself be yourself at all
times because when you're when you're
truly yourself whatever you get out of
life you will appreciate it more and
when you when you're truly being
yourself you also will never be a victim
and the reason you'll never be a victim
all you'll never practice victimology
and the reason you never practice
victimology is because you know that
whatever you got you got because you
were yourself how do you feel about like
things are happening in the past like
for example you get go to jail you get
fired from a couple of stations you
think that might have been stuff you
were putting out there that kind of came
back to you like you want to make some
dumb decisions
I mean when I was when I was getting
locked up and stuff I didn't know nobody
you know saying I see when you know
better you do better that's why I say
when I want to wanted to change my life
I changed my lifestyle so I thought it
knowing better so I started doing better
so I'll be getting fired that's just the
way things are sometimes how you come up
to me how do something oh I thought over
the Internet in 1998 when I was 18 years
old I'm 32 now there we go you want 50
be around when I'm caught up in the
internalization so I worked in every
aspect of radio I've worked in the
promotion's Department I worked in
program I was an intern for you and I
had you know I worked through the
seventh radio station I worked at I've
been fired four times you know what I'm
saying so it's like that's why when I
saw William like a William came I got
day to perform well everybody was going
to show when was a rapper who got booed
well he forced him to let him perform
again I just like the determination like
they never say with attitude the
definite you have to have it man I got
the time of five four times I got to put
a lot of time run but I don't have no
backup plan I didn't go to Congress I
don't have a degree you know I don't
have anything else to do but radio and I
used to own a rap so I realize that
revelation it's just it's so many things
that you go through in this game and so
many ebbs and flows somebody ups and
downs people that truly keep going that
make it what's your vision board look
like so you have like I'm sorry go ahead
tell me what your vision board looks
like and can you share some of the
things that are on there I just have a
traditional vision board well you know
you would take things that you want and
put them up on poster board whatever
whatever and that's cool I read you know
I did that when I did the secret but to
me the best vision was when you write
down your long-term and short-term goals
write down everything that you want to
accomplish and keep those things in your
mind because your mind is what makes
them manifest in their reality like your
thoughts really do become things like I
don't have a college degree or anything
like that all I have is back in 1998 I
said I want to be a super jock I said I
want to be one of the biggest radio
personalities on the planet I said I
want to be you know and that Wendy
Williams Tom Joyner Doug banks
Howard Stern you know Bill O'Reilly
Russell
I wanna be in that number you know when
they think of Charlemagne I want them to
think of me like that I want to be my
generation set because all of those guys
it's the natural course of thing that
power eventually fades and weakens all
of them it's just like the NBA of music
it was the Magic Johnson Larry Bird era
and it was Michael Jordan era now to
LeBron James there that's just the way
things are in the game and I knew that
eventually it would be my time if I
wanted that and so I claimed it so my
vision board is really just a notebook
with everything that I want in my life
the via truth none will be true for you
live your truth nobody can use your
truth against you and the world opens up
for honest person you know like you get
back what you put up so you're always
persistently being honest you'll get
honest things that will come back to you
and what honesty comes positivity so
when you give out positive energy you
give back positive energy you get back
positive things so that's always helping
to man let your foundation be a
foundation to honest humanity it's
always lived in truth and even when you
look on integrator look at somebody like
cardi B you know who was very famous on
Instagram you know I feel like she was
just honing a crash that's why when you
see her in front of the camera on Love &
Hip Hop she pops right she already got
an actor personality but she knows how
to operate in front of that camera right
you know so I think I think it helps I
don't think it should be your only up
campaign like I think it should be
something to cultivate your craft and
get you to a point but then it's always
another level like I look at it like a
rapper like Young at me you have ten
million views on YouTube
everybody loves you and now you gotta
get now you got to go get a record deal
if you want one you only need one of
those not maybe but if you want when you
get a record deal of you've got to
figure out how to really get a star like
you gotta look at the goals and you want
to be on the game a you want performance
be to you all but you want to win
Grammys but the reason I made it is
because I knew exactly what I wanted to
do
say ice-t with a lot of people nowadays
they became huge yeah you don't really
have a clear-cut concise goal in mind or
you don't have that one thing that they
feel that they're good at so they don't
try to master it like I'm reading the
book right now called the mastery by
Robert Greene and it basically taking
that whole 10,000 hours Theory like
you're not a master something so you put
in turns out an hour than yeah so it's
like you gotta find out one thing to put
in that time with everything else was
proud for my radio is my thing that I'm
go to they always knew in radio I wasn't
like booboo they'd go I mean fifty
actually put out some great records
earlier this year
join me out with Kendrick Lamar and he
had another record the journal official
I thought was dope but when people are
offering their off you he got his pocket
of fans that'll still support him but
you'll never see could be seen selling
10 million records Union hell you know
if you said you sent 11 million records
not one album you might do it as a
single and that's not that's not a diss
to him and just the way that's the way
hip hop is nobody cares no no you don't
saying like you good but some changes
love changes and best friends become
strangers man like it happens all the
time it happens recycles everybody can't
be jay-z you know Chris but in the
reason Jamie and Jamie has been
consistent if you drop the album every
year since 1996 my father was a was in
the construction so I used to like help
him out you know as far as building
houses and stuff like that but I didn't
really start working until I got out of
jail for the first time when I got out
of jail for the first time I did a year
in jail for son Brad we took the kids
only reason I did here so my father was
trying to teach me a lesson because I
was such a bad kid so he was trying to
teach me a lesson so instead of posting
my belly let me sit in jail and I'm like
I don't know 16 17 years of time playing
97 96 97 did so I didn't when I got out
of jails when I started saying yo and
order to change my life I got to change
my lifestyle so I didn't want to hustle
no more I never know big-time drug
dealer
oh that was a quarter spoon do you know
corresponds while I'm trying me seven
grams
you paid 250 for G flip it you made fire
on it but when I went out the first job
I started working I remember I got a job
at this warehouse called IAC dust real
acoustics company I worked and I worked
at on a flower garden I worked at Taco
Bell I worked at demo in the mall I
worked at a telemarketing place called
Paragon solutions and the reason I was
doing all that could always say you know
you got to create the kind of energy
that you want in your life if you
constantly keep creating positive energy
around you and more positive things will
come so I would be landing all these
jobs like I never was one that let my
record stop me my criminal record and
that's what eventually led me to get an
internship at derivatives because I was
just working I was working two or three
jobs at one time you know at one point I
worked at Tim on the mall Paragon
solution telemarketing agency and and
interned at the radio station it's like
the psychic telling you yo you won't be
rich one day so you just sit around and
wait to be rich I don't work like that
you know when you're constantly thinking
about doing positive things you got to
actually go out there be work towards
those goals that's why I told you
earlier about just going out and working
at Taco Bell you know working at a
warehouse just trying to create that
positive energy of production into my
life
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because in Knowles
Ashley - so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it down counts below and I'll
see what I can do
I'd also love to know what is
Charlemagne say that had the biggest
impact on you what clip resonated the
most with you and what are you going to
take as an immediate action after
watching today's video leave it down in
the comments below I'm super curious to
find out I also want to give a quick
shout out to Anthony Morgan Anthony
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word I really really
really appreciate the support and I hope
you're enjoying the read so thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself
and whatever your one where it is much
love I'll see you soon
I have all the answers you know then I
just have my experiences I'm not an
expert of nothing I only know what I've
been through and what I've lived and
things that I've adapted to my life that
have caused me to prosper so you know
I'm trying to give that to people I
don't believe in like I don't believe in
like good or bad you know I didn't
believe in like the process yeah you
don't say like I don't believe that
there's ever been anything that's really
good that happened me I'm going to do
anything that's been necessarily bad
that's happening there it's all part of
the process it's this thing called the
rule of ten the rule lieutenant people
don't like it people are not going to
like it and for people just going to be
on the fence about it like they're just
going to kind of remain neutral and just
wait to see what happens I use that
whenever I say anything in life however
I approach anything like a TV show you
know the radio show for that day our
statement I met I might make like three
people long agree with it people not and
probably musical benefits about it so
you just have to take all of that into
consideration and that kind of goes
until something my father told me a long
time ago my father said you're never as
good as they say you are
and you never as bad as they say you are
the [ __ ] personally I can don't care
either way like you know I mean the only
thing I got doing John everywhere be be
authentically me